coming up in the week in the European
Parliament helping energy consumers and
eradicating energy poverty virtual money
and a big sack of pies conference to
advance human rights welcome to the
agenda many complain that progress on
completing the e used digital single
market is far too slow leaving Europe
lagging behind in the information age
the Commission recently released
detailed plans to address that they
focus on connectivity society research
and the subject of a statement to
parliament on Wednesday by Vice
President Meryl chef kovitch
geo-blocking this is restricting access
to web content based on geographical
location a debate the same day on energy
Union aims to make sure consumers
benefit from liberalized markets now and
in the future but what does that mean
for you and me affordable and
sustainable energy plus energy efficient
products and buildings and the power to
produce consume or trade our own
renewable energy a vote on a new deal
for consumers is on Thursday Commission
vice-president chef kovitch will also
make a presentation on how to fight
energy poverty talking of poverty why is
it more women in Europe are poor than
men 65 million live in poverty well over
the 57 million men looked a single
parenthood austerity job discrimination
unequal pension rights Francis says
Maria Rena she's the author of a report
on the gender perspective of poverty the
debate is on Wednesday the vote is on
Thursday now you see it now you don't at
least you wouldn't if I was a halfway
decent magician and you certainly
wouldn't if it was virtual money like
say Bitcoin it appeared in 2009 for the
first time Parliament will be delivering
a report on Wednesday on the
implications and complexities of virtual
money a vote follows on Thursday and now
in brief here are some other highlights
of the week King vilem Alexander of the
Netherlands will address plenary on
Wednesday on Tuesday parliaments
economic affairs committee votes on
rules
tax avoidance that distort the internal
market counterterrorism is under
scrutiny in the Civil Affairs Committee
which on Monday he is updates from a
committee overseeing internal security
cooperation on the security situation in
2016 and on changes in the mood as
operandi of Islamic State on Saturday
Parliament invites the public to inspect
its inner workings earlier this month it
was in strasburg this time its Brussels
finally the 2016 conference of the
sakharov prize network takes place on
Monday and Tuesday it's designed to
advance human rights across the world
among the participants this year Denis
mukwege a sakharov prize laureate in
2014 plenty there for everyone all of
which and more you can follow on
europower TV enjoy the week so how does
this trick work now I know I can nail
this